哈喽 大家好 欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]出品的拼多多商家成长训练营
今天我们来讲一下第八节 主营类目的选择技巧
那大家都知道 在拼多多经营店铺的第一步是什么
就是选择好自己的主营类目 对吗
那今天我们会从四个板块来和大家分析
我们怎么样去选择我们的主营类目
以及我们要了解到的关键规则有哪些
那首先我们要了解到 类目的区别是根据什么来的
是根据我们的不同店铺的类型来做区分的
我们店铺类型有哪些呢
个人店，个体工商户，普通企业店，品牌店，以及我们的多多国际店
那其实在拼多多这个平台
对于个人店，个体工商户，以及普通企业店铺
对大家的一个经营范围是有非常大的一个包容空间的
它的包容空间就是重点体现在我们可以跨一级类目去选择多个类目发布产品
当然部分特殊类目除外
像虚拟商品就除外
它是不能去跨一级类目去选择的
但是我们很多普通商品覆盖了90%都是可以去跨一级类目
那这里我给大家举个例子
比如说我们拿这个手套举例子
我们点开第一个链接
你看这条链接它是在商品分类五金工具里面有一个耐磨手套的子分类
五金工具呢是在家装建材的一级类目下的分类
我们再看第二条链接
它是在居家日用
居家日用防护用品线手套
所以居家日用是在哪里
在家居生活一级类目下的二级分类
所以从此来可以很明确的看到
我们的个人店铺的经营范围是很广的
它最广的一个很明显的特点呢
就是它可以跨一级类目去选择多个类目发布产品
那么对于我们商家友好的点
就在于我们可以去不同类目去获取很多平台流量
对吗
也可以去区分我们的类目的一个竞品流量池
都是非常友好的
所以在这里的话
它适用的人群是有哪些呢
新手 卖家 小规模的个体户或者是什么
快速试水多品类的商家
或者是我们您有一个货盘
您的货盘可能有十几种或者是上百种的商品
这个时候呢
你就非常的去适合开个体个人店或者是个体混乱户
因为像这样的店铺类型呢
咱们可以去发布很多类目的商品
它是没有限制的
那么所需的核心资质也非常简单
就是一张身份证或者是一个个体的营业执照就可以了
那第二个就是我们的普通企业店铺
普通企业店铺呢
我们也是可以去夸一级类目去选择多个类目发布商品的
也是部分类目除外
那么它和个人店的一个区别在于哪呢
个人店它的需要的资质是身份证就可以了
但是我们普通企业店的话
它需要的核心资质是需要有营业执照
其他基本上都是一样的一个标准
那下面我们要说到一个非常不一样的一个店部分类
就是我们的品牌店
品牌店呢它又分为旗舰店，专卖店，专卖店，专营店
先说这三种店铺的一个共同点
品牌店铺呢是唯一主营类目且不可跨类目的
但是部分国际品牌或者是国内知名品牌是可以跨多个一级类目
大部分企业店铺呢是只有唯一主营类目
那我们那再说区别
像旗舰店呢它是需要有品牌独占授权加资质
邀约类目是需要定向开通的
什么叫独占授权
比如说我们拿到了三只松鼠
那就是三只松鼠官方旗舰店
那只能允许一个品牌它只能允许
平台开设一家官方旗舰店
它是需要有独占授权
专卖店呢
它也是需要有唯一主营类目且不可跨类目
但是呢它是可以限制什么
有单一品牌授权
某某专卖店就只能卖这个品牌旗下的
且单一类目主营类目旗下的商品
那专营店的区别跟以上这两个店的区别最大在于哪呢
它是可以多品牌授权
虽然也是唯一主营类目
但是只要是这个主营类目旗下
它可以存在有不同品牌
比如说做家访的
它可以有A品牌的授权
再上架B品牌
只要它有B品牌的授权
它也可以上架
它是有多个品牌组成的一个品牌店铺
就是专营店
那像品牌店铺的话
因为它的类目是唯一性的
所以呢它适合的人群是什么呢
品牌方或者是授权的经销商
或者是追求品牌权重与流量扶持的商家
大家都知道像品牌店铺的话
它是具备一定的品牌效益
它是有自己追随的特定人群
或者是一些黑标店铺平台都是具备有流量倾斜的
或者是有什么呢
企业店铺但是有自己的商标
且长期想在拼多多经营的商家
我未来是想奔着黑标的方向去的
那这种也是可以选择我们的品牌店铺
那第四种呢就是多多国际店
多多国际店目前在拼多多平台
它是限制只有境外的营业执照
它才可以
它是限跨境类目
限定跨境类目
那国内的能不能做呢
是不能做的
特殊类目的话
一样是需要有海关备案一些等等资质
那我们了解到了不同不同店铺的类型对于我们类目的一个选择区别以后呢
我们如果想要看到我们所有的平台的类目区分
我们可以去个人身份证注册一个全类目的店铺
这样的话我们可以看到平台的所有类目区分
目前的话以2026年1月份平台发布的一个更新的规则来看
我们是一共有45个一级类目
包括像服饰香包，数码电器，西配摩托或者是水果生鲜
一些特别类目的话它是有一些资质需要大家提供的
我们在上传的时候呢
一般都会让大家提供到这些东西
那第三个是对于我们的类目选择呢
除了个人店铺以外呢
我们像普通企业店铺呢
我们怎么选择都是根据自己商品
或者是什么营业执照的一个经营范围进行选择就可以了
那在最后我们需要强调一下
强调一下
比如说有哪些规则
像我们的主营类目修改
有一些客户他可能是注册完了店铺以后呢
会发现自己的主营类目
想要修改或者是点击错误
那这种情况下呢
可不可以修改呢
是可以的
比如说所有店铺入住后呢
可修改一次只有一次机会可以修改主营类目
并且修改以后呢
不可再改
修改需要满足无销量
无商品数据
以缴纳保证金等条件
满足了这些条件才能点击修改
审核需要人工审核七个工作日
它在七个工作日之内
一般会提前在两三个工作日就会审核成功
怎么操作呢
这里给大家演示一下
我们打开我们的店铺后台
这里有一个店铺管理
店铺信息
店铺信息这里
基本信息下面这里就可以更改主营类目
包括一些邀约类目管控
这些是有管控的
哪些属于邀约类目
像充值的
游戏生活缴费
医药健康或者是二手车
新车等
它都是为邀约类目
像这些邀约类目
像个人店
它是不可以入住的
它仅限于企业店铺 是含品牌店在内的企业店铺才可以申请
并且是需要向平台提供资质 以及提供资质以后需要人工审核
过了以后才能去进行一些修改呀 或者是入住之类的
那在这里呢 我们也要强调一点挫放类目的风险啊
挫放类目呢 其实它是我个人理解是可以分成两个板块的
一种是什么 常规的 常规的挫类目
你像我刚刚举的例子 我们的劳保手套
它这个商品 如果你是一家个人店
除了企业店 企业店铺的你肯定是只有单一类目可以选择嘛
如果是个人店铺的话
这个款它是可以具备很多种一级大类目的跨类目选择
都是有很多相关的类目 都是可以放
它是不触碰平台的规则的
但是有一些商品 你是个人店
你比如说手机壳 你想放在家居日用 可以
你想放在五金能不能放 也可以放
这是一种错类目的玩法
但是像这种非常规玩法呢
它是具备一定风险的
没有被抓到的情况下 你可能会起链接会非常快
因为你错放类目的话
你是等于说错开了一个竞品的直接竞争 会非常快
但是如果被抓到的情况下呢 平台会给你提醒
如果你不改的话 不在一定时间内改呢 会被下架商品或者是直接是降权
所以呢 这里是分两个情况来说的
还有一个呢 就是我们类目不同的话 保证金也是有差异的
基础保证金我们是500块钱 上一节课有介绍到
但是比如说特殊类目有哪些 像水果生鲜呀 酒类呀 虚拟商品呀 什么美妆呀
这些的话是不是500块钱就可以了 需要额外补缴类目保证金
这一点大家一定要明白 得根据你想操作的商品来定
那今天呢 这节课的内容就到此结束 下节课再见